en attendant je vais voir ici qui sont
avec moi et la jeunesse de bourgogne
franche comté
juliette et pauline qui sont là et
juliette qui nous disait tout à l'heure
être soucieuse de son orientation il ya
des parents sur ce plateau n'est ce pas
marilyn forcément pour ses enfants
on est toujours soucieux de son
orientation de l'orientation de ses
enfants
j'ai l'impression que c'est pas ton
souci à toi pas vraiment là que je suis
toute petite en fait ouais pratique nous
attend si tu penses à ce que tu as mal
hein j'ai toujours su pratiquement ce
que je voulais faire je me suis dit
tiens je vais travailler dans le domaine
des arts à la décoration c'est moi ça me
passionne et je veux pas faire autre
chose c'est pour ça que tu as choisi de
faire un bac pro technicien c'est ça oui
bien ouais c'est quoi un bac pro
technicien modeleur qu'est ce que tu
fais au quotidien
tu fais ce qu'on est en train de voir
juge juste là par exemple devant toi que
j'ai ici aussi que je peux montrer
regardez alors évidemment du blanc sur
blanc ses pommes c'est assez moche mais
je sais pas comment le montrer
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que voilà
c'est très joli c'est du modelage parce
que tu voulais nous parler de modelage
qu'est ce que c'est que le modelage le
mont le modelage c'est un modèle concret
en 3d ou en 2d en terre au moins deux la
trois dimensions de deux dimensions en
terre ou en plâtre et avec d'autres
matériaux pour créer ensuite l'objet que
l'on souhaite il peut également servir
de travail préparatoire à une sculpture
et à toutes sortes d'objets de
décoration en plâtre prothèse dans le
procès des prothèses dans le domaine
médical en voilà quelques images
tu peux nous commenter peut-être ça
c'est quoi c'est un moule c'est ça c'est
qu'on a fait du plâtre et en fait soit
c'est en menant le combat vers ces
combats en fait on va verser le plâtre
dans dans le moule d'accord c'est une
formation technique que tu aimes bien en
tout cas j'ai l'impression un oui ouais
je vois dans tes yeux alors là là là tu
es un petit peu une wii parce que voilà
il ya beaucoup de lumière ce matin sur
le plateau mais tu vas te détendre et
pas très inquiet alors on voit avec
quelle dextérité alors je sais pas si ce
sont tes mains mais
c'est pas grave on sent quand même qui
est une passion à ça c'est important
c'est une formation technique on dit
souvent que c'est pas très valorisé en
france oui c'est vrai que les formations
ne sont pas très valorisé en france et
c'est vraiment un tort selon moi
collectivement le bac professionnel
offre une qualification sur le marché de
l'emploi et répond elle à plusieurs
demandes des entreprises et permet de
poursuivre des études principalement en
bts et en dn match si on veut comment ça
se passe concrètement pour toi au lycée
longchamp là encore une fois quelques
images mais je reviens vraiment sur le
quotidien il y avait des parents des
grands parents qui existait à mon fils
ma fille pourrait peut-être aussi
pourquoi pas se lancer dans un lycée
technique il ya toujours quelques a
priori quand ça se passe bas à la
différence d'une formation en seconde
générale j'effectue 14 heures
d'enseignement professionnel par semaine
en atelier et tu fabriques qu alors
pendant ces 14 heures vous vous faites
quoi
qu'est-ce qui sort demain en fait déjà
on roule sur un moule avec notre main de
la terre pour voilà on fait du plâtre
aussi on calcule les proportions
qu'est-ce qu'on va naître combien de
ligue 2 d'eau aussi on va on va mettre
aussi bas les les petites poussières en
plâtre pour pour mélanger après mais on
mélange quand même pendant trois minutes
il faut après voir si notre plâtre il
colore carrément il vient un plan sur
nos doigts parce que si les
transparences et pablo faut continuer à
armer le dj majine juliette que tu dois
aussi à prendre parfois en stage oui
parce que c'est bien de les rencontrer
les professionnels de voir un peu ce
qu'ils font de modelage par exemple ça
fait partie du job ça fait le stage oui
ça c'est à la fin de mon année de
seconde en juin 2019 je dois faire un
stage de six semaines dans une
entreprise de modelage
ouais comment est-ce que tu envisages
ton avenir l'affairé demain
là je je voudrais déjà finir avoir mon
bac déjà et après faire un bts de
designers soin d'en bas travail dans
l'aimable aussi j'aimerais bien toucher
aussi bien comme dans l'émission
face-off en gros les masques faire des
masques effets spéciaux osé des choses
comme ça puisque faut voir aussi il faut
regarder la télé faut aussi se cultiver
allez comme valeur ce que je vous ai
expliqué le moment le modern art museum
alors je précise pascal allias qui se
disent ah oui c'est tout le début
d'émission c'est parce que pour la
mettre un petit peu en condition avant
l'émission
je lui demandais comment s'était passé
ses vacances elle me racontait qu'elle
avait qu'à new york qu'elle avait vu le
moma voilà quelqu un de mes élèves qui
ne connaissent pas ou il ya plein plein
plein de choses parenthèse refermée
tu me parler de choses tu sais un petit
peu l'actualité justement un petit peu
ouais toi aussi tu suis la qualité le
type de risque dans les médias il ya des
sujets qui vous intéressent en ce moment
et alléger les jeunes enfants il se
passe plein de choses
ouais bah surtout moi je veux pas qu'on
supprime les bacs pros puisque j'ai
entendu macron dire de supprimer les
bacs pros je sais plus mais je trouve ça
vraiment injuste de refaire comme au
moyen-age faut vraiment qu'ils se posent
les bonnes questions à coup c'est
vraiment pas juste alors au moins
débattre de sa maintenance et toute la
réforme des lycées professionnels à
qatar qui est en cause évidemment non
pas que je veuille éludé la question
pas du tout méritée à la parole et c'est
très bien et justement en a donné la
parole à d'autres jeunes on est parti à
la rencontre figure toi figurer toutes
les deux on est parti à la rencontre de
jeunes du collège jean philippe rameau à
dijon c'est dans le quartier de la
fontaine d'ouche pour les faire réagir à
l'actualité
voici leur point de vue nous revenons
avec pauline du lycée henri moissan de
longchamp près de genlis regarder
[Musique]
moi j'ai suivi par temps plus tard c'est
une grosse grosse manifestation on les
comprends parce que ils vont au travail
ils ont besoin d'essence et on comprend
aussi pourquoi macro que les prix de
l'essence afin concerne tout le monde
mais moi personnellement je suis pas
trop concerné ce gène ça paraît normal
ça nous intéresse parce que c'est nos
banquiers qui vivent ça mais je peux
vous les regardez
mais en fait j'étais bien intéressé par
deux choses est ce que ça vous fait
réagir quand je parlais un peu c'est le
patron de renault nissan qui a fait cas
pas déclarer tout son argent là où la
moitié sont d'argent du coup il est
ils veulent en prison un truc comme ça à
oui moi je n'ai vraiment pas entendu
parler vraiment pas et pour moi ça ne me
concerne pas du tout c'est pas la même
chose que je veux suivre
c'est ensuite toutes ces histoires on
n'a plus le temps qu'on en a trop
je sais pas c'est pas mes affaires il va
se faire arrêter ou pas ça va rien
changer à ma vie c'est quoi les un peu
les sujets qui vous intéressent
en ce moment il ya beaucoup de choses
qui se passe je sais pas
les sorties de série de nouvelles séries
sur netflix les stars et qui se marient
alors qu'on ne s'y attendait pas près
les people baby ski et je regarde
vite fait la téléralité puis je les suis
pense qu'il devine c'est pas intéressant
c'est comme si tout le monde raconté
leur vie on va pas voir le monde après y
en a c'est vrai c'est un peut-être
intéressant mais pas trop on continue
avec notre lycée qu'il a ce matin c'est
lycée henri moissan de longchamp en côte
d'or avec cette fois-ci pauline après
avoir parlé d'orientation avec toi
juliette orientations sur le modelage
j'ai bien compris avec un focus sur le
lycée technique on va plutôt de
s'intéresser à une de tes passions à toi
raconte moi ce que c'est pauline je vais
vous présenter la kpop la kpop d'accord
et là tout le monde se dit qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un trip hop salines vous savez
bon alors pourquoi déjà la capote le
beau parce que ça te plaît tout
simplement
alors c'est quoi la kpop la kia pop et
de la musique pop coréenne le cas
représente coréen et pop et le style
musical mois jusque là j'ai compris
d'accord de la capa pour retrouve
plusieurs styles musicaux comme le rap
le rock le hip hop et l'électro et
combien d'autres
ça fait du chanté pop ça oui d'accord
comment tu as découvert avec le peuple
japonais à capa pouvoir regardant des
vidéos de musique sur youtube je suis
tombé sur les deux chansons comme bbb du
groupe exo et faith du groupe ps alors
pour moi c'est des bretons je sais pas
pour vous mais une conséquence et c'est
bien justement et j'ai été emporté par
des contres les chansons du début à la
fin et c'est là où j'ai vraiment eu un
coup de coeur pour l'équipe
ouais qu'est ce qui te plaît dans cette
musique tous les champs sous les garçons
ou s'ils sont prêts à les unir
il ya le blond il ya le brun famille
halley et tous les standards ya
le rebelle il ya le bien propre sur lui
et ses mais c'est bien c'est comme ça ok
et qu'est-ce que tu as comme groupe
préférait très pop mes groupes préférés
de k-pop son exo bts et in us par il
s'est fait ils sortent du lot à mes yeux
ils sont extraordinaires
je suis fan depuis plus de quatre ans je
collectionne les albums qu'ils alors ok
les percevoir ces deux objets au plat et
assez le sweat aussi où gm a percuté
d'accord au gaumont concert ils viennent
en france simplement bas il y avait un
dernier il y avait un concert de bétail
est sans fin octobre mais j'ai pas pu y
aller c'est à paris et ça devait être
pris d'assaut les billets ont des
billets pas je pense je vous réponds
vous faire écouter un petit morceau de
musique non je vous propose un petit
extrait de contenu est alors niveau on
écoute on regarde
[Musique]
alors c'est dommage parce qu'elle
pendant que qui passe et je faisais vu
danser toutes les bougies un petit peu
parce qu'à des chorégraphies avec sagan
à un haut niveau des épaules
c'est bien ça oui mais témoin la météo à
la caméra s'il vous plaît sur eux sur
juliette juliette ont refait tout ce qui
était en train de faire là voilà bah oui
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on voie j'adore
c'est super ça excellent pauline la kpop
qu'est ce que tu dirais pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas pour les convaincre là
vraiment là alors dans la capa pour
retrouver un large choix de styles
musicaux que tout le monde connaît alors
n'hésitez pas à écouter et à découvrir
comme elle le dit c'est très scolaire
alors que tout à l'heure elle me l'a
fait dans une version copains copines ou
s'était il faut y aller à fond à la kpop
même comprend rien moi j'adore et l
appât jointe la k-pop une passion qui
permet de rencontrer des personnes
géniales et de construire une grande
amitié
tu peux peut-être aussi apprendre le
coréen pourquoi bon en tout cas c'est
génial merci à tous de votre avis